Tiffany Valentine was likely born
sometime in the late 1950s in New Jersey
based on this lot we're from Jersey
implying that both of them are Tiffany
is the older of two girls born in her
family growing up she was close to her
mother who had a lot of sayings about
relationships that stuck with her over
the years such as love is supposed to
set you free if a woman spends all day
slaving over a hot stove for a man the
least he can do is the dishes you can
always smell it on girls who sell it you
can't put a price on love never let a
man block you from what really makes you
happy if you love somebody set them free
and perhaps the one that would be the
most relevant to her once is a blessing
twice is a curse well that won't explain
your sister other than these quotes
Tiffany's childhood is surprisingly
mostly never mentioned leaving the cause
of her sadistic homicidal Behavior up to
speculation when you put all of her
mother's quotes together you realize
that they're all kind of salty takes
about relationships it makes me wonder
if Tiffany's mother left her father and
attempted to raise the girls alone the
Mrs valentine-isms come up situationally
throughout the franchise but let's try
putting them in the correct order and
building Tiffany's Story Once is a
blessing twice as occur Tiffany's
parents started off well but things
declined when her younger sister was
born because caring for a second child
was more stressful the least he can do
is the dishes Tiffany's mom becomes fed
up when her father is not pulling his
weight in household chores you can
always smell it on girls who sell it and
you can't put a price on love sounds
like as the relationship deteriorated Mr
Valentine turned to a prostitute never
lie to man block you from what really
makes you happy and if you love somebody
set them free finally she snaps and gets
divorced from Tiffany's father my guess
is that it was quite a dramatic falling
out which will help explain almost all
of Tiffany's puzzling Behavior later on
as far as we can tell she's never had
any platonic friends she's hanging out
alone at a nightclub in 1984 sipping a
martini when she's first approached by a
man who calls her red he's referring to
her red hair it's not clear if this is
her natural hair color but red is her
favorite color there's
perfume yeah maybe there is they all end
up at the hotel Hackensack where Tiffany
and the blonde get busy while the man
watches she demonstrates her aggressive
behavior by ripping off the woman's
necklace while she is distracted the man
Yanks her off the bed and gestures a
knife in her Direction instead of
cowering away she just smiles and eggs
him on do it
do it to me it's me now her
aggressiveness with the woman and
masochism with the man is enough to make
me think that Tiffany had already
discovered her bloodlust prior to
meeting this couple and she was probably
at that nightclub looking for prey she
was wearing a leopard pattern after all
she is identifying herself as a predator
the man locks eyes with her for a minute
and the blonde gets jealous in an
unexpected move he stabs the blonde
instead of the redhead and invites
Tiffany to play in the Carnage with him
she proceeds to stab the woman seven
more times as she breaks down into cries
of joy and laughter
yeah
it's never happened
that's probably exactly what she's
talking about here but it does further
my suspicion that this isn't the first
chapter of her crime career the two
passionately make love beside the mess
they just created she introduces herself
and when she learns his name Charles
she's the one who suggested he go by
Chucky he gives her a suggestion as well
to go blind these suggestions each
become iconic elements of their
respective characters and so began one
of the worst most toxic romances I've
ever [__] seen to learn how Tiffany's
childhood shaped her into a monster
these secrets behind her survival the
disturbing truth about her motherhood
and how her career is a professional
poker player helps her carry out an evil
plot in the future stick around to the
end of this video
[Music]
welcome to Horror history there are not
many characters who have the power to
revitalize a franchise so many years in
after Child's Play 3 in 1991 producers
Don Mancini and David kirschner were
inspired to create a fresh take for
Chucky after seeing the way that scream
reinvigorated the horror genre with
satire something they talked about on
the movie's official website back in the
days when movie websites didn't suck the
fourth Chucky film became more of a
romantic comedy by introducing a love
interest for these supernaturally
possessed doll enter Tiffany Valentine
or she would become known Tiffany Ray
Tiffany is a name of Greek origin
meaning manifestation of God she would
be the second character ever to be aided
by the power of the voodoo God of Dan
Bella and Valentine refers to the
holiday of love and romance Valentine's
Day Tiffany's entire character has been
influenced by her mom's distorted
teachings about love although the fan
base is split on the comedic approach to
Chucky which I refer to as the bride
seed Arc most would agree that Tiffany
has become a fan favorite character who
stuck around even after the movie swung
back to a horror first approach from an
emotional standpoint there's a lot going
on with his character so let's take it
back to her 20s to understand how she
got so messed up
[Music]
Tiffany is referred to as a body
disposal expert it's clear that she has
no sense of morality but her skill when
it comes to cleaning up after herself at
least keeps her from facing any murder
charges in her 20s that being said her
disregard for other laws still got her
in trouble often Landing her with jail
time and a mug shot in the newspaper
I always dreamed of having a big big
church wedding with bridesmaids and a
cake in my picture in the paper not just
the usual mugshot but something really
flattering at some point authorities
distinguished her from being a common
criminal and determined that mental
illness was a factor this puppy ill the
courts thought so she's somehow able to
stay out of an institution I would
conclude that her life of crime links to
mental illness was a direct result of
her upbringing her mother's philosophies
make it clear that there was a lot of
friction between Tiffany's parents this
medically reviewed article by clinical
social worker Amy Marin describes the
Mental effects that fighting parents can
have on a child a lot of these describe
Tiffany's Behavior but for now let's
just look at behavior problems parental
conflict has been linked to increased
aggression delinquency and conduct
problems in children as these kids
develop into adults behavior problems in
school become run-ins with the law
inability to fit in with society and mug
shots in the paper shortly after she
hooked up with Chucky Chucky actually
killed Tiffany's mother the woman that
Tiff is constantly quoting yeah she
stays with Chucky after this and even
wants to spend more time with them I
always wanted us to spend more time
together maybe do some traveling and see
the world this suggests that in her
adulthood she didn't have a good
relationship with her mother which could
likely be a lingering effect if Parental
fighting it can affect the parent-child
relationship the quality of the
relationship may be affected as it may
be difficult for parents to show warmth
and affection when they're angry and
upset with the other parents I can
basically go on and on about how
parental quarrels may have impacted her
for example it can cause insecurity
Tiffany gets a tattoo on her chest a
heart with a dagger and her boyfriend's
name this study in the National Library
of Medicine found that young women with
tattoos reported significantly lower
self-esteem I'm not saying all tattoos
bad I have a tattoo but the difference
is mine is perfect and I had a long time
to think about it Tiffany's is a tacky
emotional crutch that she got to impress
a man that doesn't actually care about
her Tiffany also becomes a big fan of
Martha Stewart the article states that
women who watch Martha Stewart have
significantly I'm kidding after a few
years of dating and committing crimes
together in Hackensack it was time for
these two fish to move to a bigger pond
or should I say Lake but first there was
one order of business to take care of
[Applause]
before leaving New Jersey Chucky and
Tiffany need a vehicle and the two look
at this 1960 Pontiac Parisienne Tiffany
loves the color Coronado red because
it's her favorite color and it can
easily hide spatters of blood when the
seller discloses that the previous
owners were decapitated in the car she
gets a huge smile she gleefully slashes
the seller's throat with her nail file
and climbs into the driver's seat she
also takes a little taste of his blood
along with weaponizing her nail file
this is something that becomes a
signature of hers as they set off she
notices Chucky reading something about
Voodoo something that would become a
very big part of her life later on they
arrive in Chicago Illinois in 1988 and
get their first apartment together she's
immediately Blown Away by it and begins
interior designing in her head and
Martha Stewart has been rubbing off on
her Charles suggests they order a pizza
and she loves the idea because she knows
exactly what that means not only are
they ordering a pizza but they're also
ordering a pizza delivery man and new
victims are just as satiating as deep
dish for these two they share a
cigarette afterwards as they debate the
merits of Chicago vs jersey style pizza
the scene also contains more potential
evidence that Discord from her youth is
still affecting her and another Telltale
sign is substance abuse something that
becomes much more likely in a high
conflict family but at least at this
point the young couple is getting along
like substance abuse violence seems to
be something that can numb over any
relationship issues I think a lot of
people have had that X that just isn't
really compatible with you but when
you're in bed everything is good for
these two it's offing people and like
that X there's a limited amount of times
you can turn to this distraction before
the relationship issues are impossible
to ignore as they stop hunting together
as frequently tension rises in the
relationship at the time of the original
movie Chucky has his own play so my
theory is that they broke up causing him
to move out but they got back together
and Chucky just kept his other
apartments to use for other purposes
besides he's definitely not getting his
deposit back seeing as what he's done
with the place Chucky starts seeing
another woman at this point however it's
not clear if Tiffany knew about this I
don't think she did but I'll get back to
that later on November 8th 1988 Tiffany
comes home from the grocery store with
ingredients to make Chucky's favorite
food Swedish meatballs and catches him
in the other room finishing some lady
with a knife that's not an innuendo I
mean literally but to her stabbing solo
is just as bad as cheating she's jealous
that he's getting his fix without her a
new form of jgs that we've never
explored before she confronts him on
their lack of murder dates as of late
and he just blows off the argument it's
obvious that this isn't the first time
that they've separated without being
able to talk out the problem it's a
symptom of one of the biggest effects of
Parental infighting relationship issues
it's pretty obvious how this goes as a
kid your brain is still developing and
adapting to your environment when kids
see their parents fighting all the time
they learn that that's how you solve
disputes and they end up using the same
tactics in their own personal
relationships which means toxic
relationships instead of trying to fix
the issue she tries to get back at her
boyfriend she calls the police station
and asks for Detective Mike Norris the
lead detective on the Lakeshore
Strangler case and fills him in on
Charles whereabouts this leads to the
police finding where he's kidnapped his
mistress chasing him through Chicago and
ultimately killing him inside of a toy
store after his death Tiffany finds a
ring on the mantle and believes that
Chucky had been planning to propose to
her Tiffany does know that Charles had
been experimenting with Voodoo and keeps
hope alive that he might have been able
to transfer soul out of his body before
dying so she continues to wear the ring
every day she searched for 10 years
there are rumors and urban legends of a
possessed Good Guy doll that first
appeared right after Charles death in
1988 then again in 1990 but the alleged
activity always dissipates before
Tiffany can get there she's forced to
move to a mobile home in Lockport New
York I'm guessing she moved there in
1998 or 1999 because at the time of
Bride of Chucky in Spring 1999 it sounds
like she hasn't been there for very long
so you're moving out already she keeps
the ring in the car but nothing else her
belief in Chucky's return is so strong
that she fantasizes about having a baby
with him when he comes back and builds a
slide-out playpen in her trailer the
place is decorated all over with baby
dolls it's possible that she just has an
obsession with dolls because of the
legends about her boyfriend becoming a
doll but based on her past I have a
different Theory I talked about the
emotional damage she received from her
parents fighting with each other but
perhaps the stressful home environment
also led to one of the parents abusing
her these victims tend to have their
emotional development stunted in other
words the trauma may freeze their
brain's development it's making them
unable to grow up in certain ways this
could explain the baby dolls the little
girl voice associated with many of these
types of victims awake
[Music]
childlike tantrums and many other
symptoms some of which overlap with the
psychological damage caused by fighting
between parents I'm not going to dwell
on this too much because there's no
evidence that she was abused it's
possible that she just likes dolls but I
wouldn't be surprised if we end up
learning that her parents were a little
heavy-handed with her it seems like
she's about to move on from Chucky by
1999. she starts dating a cringy goth
dude named Damien but doesn't put out
for him because in her words I'll kill
anybody but I'll only sleep with someone
I love and she doesn't love him because
he's not a real killer like chunky in
1999 she hears about another potential
Chucky appearance at a military academy
in Missouri the remains of the good guy
doll end up in an Evidence Locker nearby
so she bribes a cop named Robert Bailey
to retrieve them for her only to slit
his throat with her nail file and
collect the spoils she goes home to sew
the doll back together and attempts to
bring it back to life with the help of
her Voodoo for dummies book it doesn't
appear to work at first however Damien
comes over and she soon notices that the
doll has moved she gets the idea to
chain Damien to the bed and strip tease
for both him and the doll anybody even
looked me
Chucky would take care of him wouldn't
you Chucky this is her cue Chucky turns
his head to lock eyes with Damian and
Tiffany looks on as her ex rips out her
new boyfriend's piercing and Smothers
him with a pillow bringing someone to an
early grave is what started Tiffany and
Chucky's relationship and it also
provides a spark for them to rekindle
that relationship here the couple are
glad to see each other for a couple of
minutes before they go back to being
toxic as [__] it's part of a long cycle
which we see more examples of it doesn't
take long for the friction between them
to start up again when Chucky makes an
off-putting comment I always thought you
were gonna Let Yourself Go nonetheless
she prepares him his favorite meal
Swedish meatballs and explains how she
never stopped wearing his ring she is
dismayed to find out that Charles had
stolen the ring in order to sell it not
to propose to her when he hysterically
laughs in her face she realizes that he
hasn't changed and probably never will
she locks him in her makeshift playpen
and tells him she prefers him in this
baby-like form I think what she really
likes is having control over him since
his independent behavior is what caused
issues for them in the past the bedroom
is one thing but hopefully I don't have
to explain why it's not a good idea to
get involved with a woman who is a
control freak in all aspects of life
this is another aspect of her character
that stays with her through the years
that night she removes her ring for the
first time and weeps in her bed next to
Damien's lifeless bottle the next day
she would look for love elsewhere but
her search and her life would be cut
short
[Music]
the next day Tiffany gets her neighbor
and Jesse Miller to help her load the
trunk containing Damien's body into the
car she asked Jesse out on a date that
evening but Jesse has a girlfriend so
Tiffany tells him to treat her right and
heads off to dumps Damien in the East
River which according to Buffalo native
and fellow YouTube Creator Bryce Edward
Brown is the prime location to dump
bodies in New York I'm not sure why he
knows that on the way back she buys a
female doll about Chucky's size and puts
it into the playpen with him to be his
new partner to taunt him that evening
she takes a bath and Giggles as she
watches the news report on her most
recent string of victims before
switching to Bride of Frankenstein which
he seems moved by perhaps because of the
monster's unconditional interest in the
bride upon their meeting while Tiffany
is distracted Chucky escapes his cage
and pushes her TV into the bath causing
her to be electrocuted to death this is
where most people do that joke that the
video is over but I'm kind of sick of
that Meme so let's just skip to the part
where Chucky transfers her soul into the
female doll and she wakes up realizes
what happens and is horrified with both
of them in doll form Chucky wants to
marry her so she can love serve and Obey
him hopefully I don't have to explain
why it's not a good idea to get involved
with someone who has those intentions
Tiffany is more interested in
transferring back into a human body but
Chuck explains that to do that they need
an amulet called the heart of dembele
which was buried with Chucky's corpse in
Hackensack New Jersey they come up with
a plan to get Jesse to drive them to the
cemetery for one thousand dollars under
the ruse that Tiffany can't deliver the
dolls because she's taking care of a
friend who's mentally incapacitated
foreign
she gives herself a makeover to look
more like her human self which I don't
get because she's planning to go back to
a human form in just a couple days women
next there's a scene that isn't shown in
any movie but it's kind of important to
talk about Chucky and Tiffany hi to
Tiffany's discarded human body somewhere
so that Jesse doesn't come into the
trailer and Discover It rotting there
this works to their advantage much later
on but we'll get to that after finding
Tiffany's note Jesse makes an unexpected
stop to pick up his girlfriend Jade with
plans to run away and get married which
Tiffany finds romantic but Chucky finds
sick in it oh that's so romantic I give
him six months
three if she gains weight they watch as
Jade's Uncle the Lockport Police Chief
Warren Kincaid tries to plant drugs in
Jesse's van so Tiffany creates a trap
using Nails in an airbag designed to
kill Warren when he goes to investigate
her giggling in the front seat they hide
the chief under the back seat before
Jesse and Jade get back they must have
been able to hoist him up there due to
the super strength afforded by dumbbell
when did Jesse and Jade come back they
stay in a Barbie mode around humans to
try to get to their destination without
raising suspicion the van immediately
gets pulled over by another cop the
chief's Lackey officer Norton as he
searches the vehicle Tiffany kicks him
in the head to prevent him from finding
Warren's body but as a result he does
find the drugs that were planted there
wanting to keep their Journey on track
and their chauffeur out of prison Chucky
borrows tips lighter and she watches
with delight as he uses it to ignite
officer norn's gas tank
Jesse speeds away from the scene which
Tiffany refers to as Chucky still
knowing how to show a girl a good time
once again all logic about the
compatibility of their relationship goes
out the window for her when she sees
Chucky do what he does best the two
dolls gave as Jesse and Jade bicker
about what just actually happened they
stopped at a small Chapel in Niagara
Falls to tie the knot and Tiffany shares
her longtime dream of getting married
which actually causes Chucky to stop and
actually give her a real apology I guess
being back on the run from the law with
her reminded him of their younger days
and struck a chord with him every time
blood spills they seem to get a little
bit closer to add to the romance Warren
who is somehow still alive pops up in
the back of the van and Chucky stabs him
in the back to finish the job that night
they all stay in the honeymoon suites
motel in Niagara where another couple
barges into Jesse and Jade's room and
Tiffany notices the woman steal Jesse's
wallet obviously this woman doesn't know
that dolls are alive so Tiffany ends up
being the only one to see this happen
and it enrages her I'm guessing Tiffany
is not suddenly taking some kind of
moral High ground and that this is more
about trying to ensure that their
journey is not interrupted again she
sneaks into their room and hurls their
champagne bottle at the mirror on the
ceiling causing it to shatter and slice
them apart on the way down the first
example of Tiffany's very impressive
throwing arm Chucky is absolutely
smitten after seeing this
I love you he steals the ring finger of
the newly deceased newlywed and uses it
to propose to Tiffany for real this time
and she's brought to tears from this
point she goes by Tiffany Ray after
realizing she has one human bodily
function her tears the two decide to
test another Chucky believes that he
doesn't need to use a rubber because
he's all rubber despite actually being
made of plastic so the two brush it off
and continue their intimate moment this
moment would have dire consequences
Tiffany becomes pregnant and because the
two dolls are being kept Alive by The
Power of Voodoo this is a voodoo
pregnancy which means everything is
accelerated and only takes a couple of
days until delivery despite that they
don't realize that they've just
conceived a child later that night they
come up with a plan to transfer their
souls into Jesse and Jade's bodies once
they've reacquired The Amulet the next
morning they have to make a quick exit
when the maid discovers the bodies of
the other honeymooning couple and Jesse
and Jade are surprised by the appearance
of their friend David who shows up to
help with the Newfound relationship
issues being caused by the murderous
dolls that they're Towing when David
accidentally finds Warren's decomposing
remains in the back he grabs the chief's
gun and demands that they pull over just
as a passing top recognizes Jesse's van
and approaches the change in
circumstances forces Chucky and Tiffany
to make themselves known by pulling out
guns of their own which I have no idea
how they obtained and take the three
humans hostage this frightens David so
much that he backs himself into oncoming
traffic so Tiffany gives Jesse the order
too get this heap of [__] moving after
getting away they steal an RV from an
older couple by shooting them in the
head so that they won't be recognized on
the road Tiffany ties up Jade and gives
her a makeover presumably preparing for
the moment that she moves in to Jade's
body she also makes some meatballs and
cookies in the oven for her new husband
but quickly becomes enraged when Chucky
makes a comment about the dishes not
being cleaned Jade and Jesse make a
couple strategic remarks to kind of turn
Tiffany and Chucky against each other
Jade edges Tiffany to retaliate after
feeling underappreciated and this starts
a huge fight which includes dish
throwing bickering and insulting
Chucky's manhood take it from me honey
plastic is no substitute for a nice
Uncle wood Jade uses the distraction to
kick Tiffany into the oven and the RV
crashes in the ensuing chaos
conveniently right into the cemetery
where they need to go Tiffany's skin
bakes inside the oven increasing her
rage even further she busts out and
attacks Jade biting her in the ear
before Jesse grabs her and throws her
out the window she's unable to get to
her gun before Jesse and he takes her as
a hostage to counter Chucky who is
holding Jade at gunpoint they come up to
the Grave plot of Charles Lee Ray where
the examination is currently in progress
when Jesse and Tiffany get there Chucky
has recovered the ambulance the two make
an exchange Jade will go back to Jesse
in exchange for Chucky getting Tiffany
back but something is different about
her demeanor this time around she's
really had it with Chucky we see the
difference in how Jesse and Chucky treat
their women Jade falls into Jesse's arms
but Chucky lets Tiffany fall to the
ground this allows Tiffany to see how
she wants to be treated versus how she's
actually treated in real time and for
her this is the final straw
[Music]
Jesse and Jade find themselves tied up
by Chucky who attempts to perform the
dembele a chance to possess their bodies
but before completing the ritual Tiffany
tells Chucky that she loves him and that
they belong together but while kissing
him she steals his knife and uses it to
stab him in the back before clarifying
that they do belong together they belong
together in Hell the two fights and
Chucky stabs her in the chest but she at
least creates enough of a distraction
for Jesse to knock Chuck down into the
Open Grave where he's ultimately killed
once more after the dust settled the
lead detective on the Jesse and Jade
case discovered Tiffany's charred
remains and she Springs to life with the
very last of her energy to give birth to
a child before she gives out in a way
fulfilling her mother's prophecy that
love would set her free it's not known
exactly how but Chucky and Tiffany's
doll bodies end up in the hands of a
movie studio rather than in another
evidence Locker Tiffany's human body is
still never discovered she remains dead
for another five years until March 18
2004. the dolls have been adapted into
animatronics which are being used to
shoot a movie called Chucky goes psycho
in which Tiffany helps Chucky defeat a
man pretending to be Santa Claus during
a break they're sitting in a prop room
when their child who has since been
given the name [__] face finally tracks
them down and reads the inscription
found on the back of the heart of
dunbella which brings both Chucky and
Tiffany to life with a jolt of
electricity Tiffany's motherly instincts
immediately kick in and she asks where
his parents are before realizing who he
really is as the two Embrace she calls
him sweet face the same name that she
had given to Jesse when she was hitting
on him maybe this is not that big of a
deal but I do find it a little bit
off-putting that she time and time again
has shown no separation between romantic
love and Mother Love we see it again
much later when she reunites with the
doll Chucky AKA her husband and treats
him like a little baby but we've got a
lot to cover before we can even begin to
unpack that and I'm not saying it's
weird for couples to use pet names like
a lot of people do that although it is
cringe but it's more the way that
Tiffany does it in addition to her other
pre-existing derangements that makes me
feel that this is just another example
of Tiffany's poorly adjusted behavior
before sweetface can finish filling them
in on where they are the animatronic
effects artist comes in to work on
Tiffany but gets a shock upon opening
her up to find real human organs Chucky
tosses a length of string around the
man's neck and Tiffany helps do the
honors of decapitating him with it once
again this act overwhelms the two of
them with passion and all past drama is
forgotten as they share a kiss which is
interrupted by the sound of their kid
pissing his or her pants come to think
of it they never did get around to the
whole gender reveal party considering
they were both killed right as he was
born so when they go to check things out
for themselves the kid has no genitals
just as you would expect from a
children's doll Tiffany wants her child
to be a girl and while Chucky wants a
son Chucky names the kid Glenn and
Tiffany goes with Glenda the
nomenclature was inspired by the 1953
drama film Glenn or Glenda I'm just
gonna go with Glenn for now to make
things easier the gender disagreement
would be the source of a lot of
confusion for the child later on but
before arguing any further they're
interrupted by Hollywood actress
Jennifer Tilly who was using this room
as a secret snacking location Tiffany is
Star Struck upon seeing her Idol perhaps
Miss Tilly was an inspiration to her
because she looks and sounds just like
Tiffany did when she had a human body
Jennifer Tilly soon realizes that the
decapitated head on the ground is no
movie prop and the movie gets shut down
to let the crime scene procedures begin
the frenzy of Paparazzi provides a
distraction for Tiffany and her boys to
sneak out and Stow themselves away in
Jennifer Tilly's limo Tiffany is dazzled
by the sight of the Hollywood Sunset and
it seems to inspire her to develop a new
plan to be a part of that SoCal stardom
by transferring her soul into Jennifer
Tilly's body and for Chucky to take over
the body of rapper slash movie producer
Redman so that they can be the most
powerful couple in Hollywood
however and that leaves Glenn still
needing a body and Tiffany doesn't want
to get pregnant again so she plans to
knock out Jennifer before performing The
Soul transfer ritual using her as what
she calls a surrogate mother and what
the rest of us call human trafficking I
think sometimes Tiffany likes to
recontextualize the horrible things that
she does to distract her from how
horrible they are like earlier on when
she refers to her killing sprees with
Chucky as dates as they put their child
to sleep that evening he asked the
question that they're not prepared for
why do you kill people Chucky wants his
kid to grow up to become a killer but
Tiffany thinks they should set a good
example now that their parents and she
nags Chucky until he reluctantly agrees
to stop killing mostly to shut her up
later that night Tiffany sends Chucky
into the bathroom with a cup to start
the artificial insemination process and
later knocks out Redman with Mrs
Tilley's most improved actress award she
confronts and scolds Jennifer on her
lack of self-respect for trying to sleep
her way into a role then immediately
changes tones and asks her hero for an
autograph which of course freaks
Jennifer the [__] out maybe that was
part of the plan Jennifer runs for it so
Tiffany once again displays her
impressive Cannon of an arm and Nails
her in the back of the head with a
trophy the two dolls drag the
unconscious movie stars to bed once
again we see the added strength that the
magic of dumbbella gives to help them
move these bodies but even still she's
fat
can't believe it she's not even pregnant
yet Tiffany is the one to
um decorates the cake the next morning
is March 19th and Tiffany's plan works
because Jennifer wakes up thinking her
battle with the three foot plastic
superfan was all a dream meanwhile Tiff
reads up on kicking her addiction to
committing homicide she kind of skims
through the first eight steps but the
ninth tells her to make amends with
anyone she might have harmed so she
starts by calling up Ruth Bailey the
Widow of the police officers that she
killed five years earlier her apology
confuses and distresses Miss Bailey but
Tiffany seems oblivious which I see as
another coping mechanism to help her
ignore how harmful her actions really
are in the evening Jennifer tells red
man that she's pregnant again the signs
show up much faster than usual because
the father is being kept Alive by Voodoo
thus making it a voodoo pregnancy Redman
informs her that he got a vasectomy so
he can't be the father and adds that she
can no longer be in his movie because in
his words she gots to be hot Tiffany
overhears their conversations with
events and is outraged and tempted to
kill Redman herself but she resists the
urge and calls up his support hotline
instead the guy that she talks to is
very unhelpful though and almost
encourages her by saying that having a
slip up is okay because Rome wasn't
built in a day it's unclear if this is a
sport hotline specifically for serial
killers or just a hotline for all types
of addicts at first I thought it was a
hotline for all types of addicts which
would explain why he doesn't make a huge
deal out of her having a slip up but
again I'm not sure what he's talking
about with this line
believe in me it was not
perfect It To Me 3
. I guess he could be talking about a
messy maid while he was drunk or
something but it almost sounds like it
actually is a serial killer hotline
regardless his advice encourages Tiffany
to invite herself to dinner with red man
that evening
Glennon notices his mother cutting out
Red Man's intestines and Tiffany is
embarrassed to have broken her vow in
front of him an event that he doesn't
really know how to process the next
morning March 20th Chucky and Tiffany
watched the execution of Martha Stewart
in bed when they hear Jennifer's
horrified reaction about her now very
visible pregnancy Jennifer calls her
assistant to vent about this scary new
development and Tiffany joins in on the
call to confuse and torture them since
her voice is identical to Jennifer she
finds Chucky tying Jennifer to the bed
and he accidentally drops a photo of him
and Glenn killing the paparazzi this
sets her off because of their agreement
not to kill anyone to set a good example
for their child a huge argument ensues
and it's not long before they're back on
their disagreement of if they should
raise a boy or a girl there's a lot of
irony here after all of her fuss to
create a good environment to raise a
child by shielding him or her from
violence she ends up putting him or her
in the very same environment she likely
grew up in a household with two parents
who are constantly fighting Glenn states
he or she cannot decide exactly what he
or she wants to be but knows that he or
she is not a killer and Tiffany says
that this makes her proud Chucky finds
Redman's body in the wardrobe so she's
got to call in a new male body for
Chucky to transfer into which would be
Jennifer's limo driver Stan
right there sing it's not really clear
to me why they couldn't just still use
Redman as being alive has never been a
prerequisite for possessing a body
before how else would they have gotten
into doll bodies in the first place when
Stan arrives they take him prisoner as
well and Tiffany thinks they're a cute
couple as she did with Jesse and Jade
her mother's teachings seemed to have
imparted this idealized version of love
that her toxicity prevents her from
actually achieving the vitriol between
Chucky and Tiffany continues to build as
they prepare for the birth of the baby
and subsequently the three Soul transfer
rituals
with Chucky's call upon the voodoo
powers of dumbbell illuming and an
interruption arises in the form of
Jennifer Tilly's concerned personal
assistant Chucky finds a hiding spot so
that he can surprise and take care of
her while Tiffany steps out of the room
and grab a drink when she comes back
she's faced with a very different
situation Glenn has now changed his
identity and appearance to Glenda in
order to murder Jen's assistant with a
makeshift flamethrower
what did I miss Tiffany is taken aback
by The Psychotic new Behavior even if
she did get what she wanted by Glenn
accusing the female identity she slaps
Glenda in the face telling her to wake
up and this seems to revert her back
into being Glenn essentially these are
two identities living in one body if
you've seen psycho it helped Inspire
this concept which I talk more about in
the things you missed episode on Seed of
Chucky before they have time to really
sort this out it's time to deliver the
baby and Tiffany serves as the Midwife
it's a boy yes we can tell by the blue
blanket that you somehow have however to
Tiffany's surprise there's also a second
Twin and this one's a girl with three
human bodies collected plus one extra
it's time to perform the voodoo ritual
Tiffany interrupts to allow Glenda the
opportunity to choose which twin she
wants to inhabit but realizes since they
have the amulet this Choice doesn't have
to be permanent the cops show up so she
rushes Chucky along to perform the
ritual and with everyone screaming at
him he snaps and backs out of the whole
thing she's unwilling to change her
course she's seen the opportunity for
Hollywood stardom and she chooses that
life over an eternity as a doll and
breaks up with Chucky
it's over there's just one problem you
don't break up with the Chuck he
attempts to throw a knife at her but
she's saved by Stan Breaking Free at
just the right time or from his point of
view just the wrong time she throws the
blade back at her now ex doll but with
the police just outside and on their way
upstairs all three Toys have to duck out
Tiffany and Glenn are able to hitch a
ride with the ambulance and sneak into
the hospital room where Jennifer Tilly
is being tended to they hide under the
bed and listen in on the latest
information the police have somehow
cleared her of being the killer despite
being the only witness of the effects
guy's death red man's death her limo
driver's death her assistant's death and
three other people found the dead in her
home which makes no sense but the police
aren't convinced that she's mentally
competent and might not let her see her
newborn children Tiffany injects
something into her IV which causes her
to pass out and once again tries to
proceed with the soul transfer ritual
[Music]
like her initial spell to try to
reawaken Chucky there's something about
how Tiffany performs the ritual that
causes the effects to be delayed and
this allows Chucky time to get inside
and lodging ax into her head with her
dying word she tells Glenn to be a good
girl or boy and not to make the same
mistakes that she and Chucky did
especially
but these aren't really her last words
obviously as you can see there's more
time left in the video the soul transfer
takes effect and she rolls over now in
Jennifer's Body not you Jennifer Tilly's
body but seeing his mother get chopped
up awakens something inside of Glenn and
he goes ninja mode Tiff slides into the
ax and he uses it to finish Chucky once
and for well once after the deed is done
she tries to console her son who is
surely full of confusing emotions at
this point we can assume they next took
the amulet to the nursery to transfer
Glenn and Glenda into their human bodies
when the ritual was performed they
really did switch places at first it
appeared that Jennifer Tilly switched
into the doll body then died immediately
but apparently she actually survived and
Tiffany held on to the doll to use
Jennifer to her Advantage she put her to
work forcing her to do her taxes play
online poker and even do voice over work
as Bonnie on Family Guy all of this so
Tiffany could live the life of luxury
for years to come Tiffany took over
Jennifer Tilly's life but she was really
worried that Jennifer's close relatives
would notice something was off about her
behavior So to avoid any suspicion she
cut off contact with them Tiffany didn't
want the twins to feel lonely and
without a sense of extended family so
she started organizing regular
get-gathers with Jennifer's actor
friends the get-togethers included bound
co-stars Gina Gershon and Joe pantoliano
as well as Sutton Strack and they became
like the twins aunts and uncles around
this time it was likely that the movie
Seed of Chucky went into production as
Jennifer Tilly has a seat of Chucky
poster in her home also note that
Jennifer Tilly was credited for being in
Bride of Chucky but I assumed that came
out before Tiffany took over the release
dates of these movies in the Chucky
Universe obviously doesn't align with
the release dates in our world all of
this happens before the twins fifth
birthday on March 20th 2009. Tiffany has
assumed the life of Jennifer Tilly so
she's holding a big party at her
Hollywood Hills mansion as a single
mother she's hired a new nanny fulvia to
help look after the kids who loves Glenn
but literally fears Glenda Tiffany uses
the doll to beat down fulvia in an act
of Revenge for her disloyalty at the
time it appeared to be just an object
not moving and not alive it's possible
that this was Jennifer though holding
entirely still or maybe she just
acquired multiple Wedding Bell dolls
during this she once again writes this
off as a little slip so she's continuing
to use Rome wasn't built in a day as an
excuse to continue her killing career it
seems she has an understanding with
Glenda the murderers of the two kids to
keep all of this quiet maintaining the
illusion of a perfect family for Glenn
which is what he wants more than
anything she likely continued living as
a Hollywood movie star and poorly
parenting your kids through the turn of
the decade at some point she went back
across the country to retrieve her car
which was left outside her old trailer
in Lockport New York Glenn and Glenda
would be eight years old at the
beginning of 2013 when Chucky next pops
up we don't know if there was an event
that caused Tiff to get back together
with him yet again after the dramatic
breakup in nearly a decade before all we
know is that Chucky somehow shows up at
the front door of the woman he was
seeing in 1988 right before he got
killed Sarah Pierce it's possible that
somebody helped Pack and Mail Chucky to
Sarah's doorstep but if that is the case
I don't think it was Tiffany that helped
him because as I alluded to earlier I
don't think Tiffany ever knew about
Sarah and Chucky wouldn't want to put
himself in a situation where Tiffany
starts asking questions about who this
woman actually is there's no way she
would help him when she found out Chucky
doesn't necessarily need Tiffany's help
to package and mail himself for example
in Child's Play 3 he mails himself to
the military academy despite not having
connected with her yet we can only
assume he tricks someone else into
helping him or he somehow does it
himself it's not really explained
anyways after arriving in Rhode Island
Chucky massacres the Pierce family and
the only survivors are Sarah's daughter
Nica Pierce and granddaughter Alice
Pierce there's a very public trial in
April 2013 where the Chucky dolls used
as a key piece of evidence and Anika is
blamed for the murders and Rule to be
insane Tiffany probably heard about this
in the news and realized that Chucky was
back and started to fall for him again
because she can't resist a killer it's
an inescapable cycle for her on April
6th or 7th the day that Nika's trial
ended she pulls out an old trick by
bribing a police officer to bring her
the evidence aka the Chucky doll before
grabbing him from behind and slashing
his throats the same thing she did to
Robert Bailey 14 years before presumably
Chucky and Tiffany rekindled their
relationship and Tiffany agrees to help
him with his plan by mailing him to his
next destination where Chucky tricks
Alice into letting him perform the chant
and to take over her body after doing so
Tiffany goes through the adoption
process to become Alice's legal guardian
using the name Tiffany Valentine
important note she did not sign the
adoption paperwork as the movie star
Jennifer Tilly did anyone ever tell you
to look exactly like Jennifer Tilly yeah
I get that a lot remember when I said
that Chucky and Tiffany hiding Tiffany's
original human body would be important
later this is why Tiffany is an expert
at disposing of human remains so nobody
ever finds her original corpse this
allows her to be Jennifer in her
day-to-day life but also Tiffany
whenever it's convenient for her if
Jennifer had tried to adopt Alice there
would have been a huge Spotlight on her
and if something were to happen to Alice
it wouldn't look good considering that
Miss Tilly was the sole witness of six
murders that took place in her house in
2004 but since Tiffany is the one
adopting the child people aren't really
going to be paying attention this also
goes back to what I said earlier about
Tiffany not distinguishing romantic love
for motherly love from the outside it's
a random woman taking in an orphaned
little girl but from her point of view
she's adopting her lover which is weird
after Alice's usefulness eventually runs
its course she is allegedly killed
something that Tiffany later expresses
regret for even here she can't fully
suppress her motherly instincts I'm
assuming Tiffany was also the person to
mail one duplicate Chucky to Andy
Barkley's apartment six months later on
November 8th 2013 though it didn't end
well for him Andy
this doesn't really matter though
because by this time Chucky has
discovered a new spell on Voodoo for
dummies.com that allows him to split his
soul into multiple different bodies
Tiffany would also find uses for the
spell and Chucky and Tiffany's
relationship would get a whole lot more
interesting
[Music]
by the year 2017 Tiffany and Chucky are
somehow still on good terms or at least
they're back on good terms who knows how
many times they broke up from 2013 to
2017. Chucky's new plan is to create an
entire Army of Chucky dolls using the
voodoo for dummies.com spell it seems
that there's a limit to how many times
he can replicate his soul individually
but if he can get an innocent to kill
for him he can automatically possess a
massive number of dolls Tiffany is in on
this plan she does her part by visiting
the psychiatric hospital where Nika
Pierce is being held in captivity on
January 23rd when Nika enters the room
Tiffany can be seen sharpening her
deadly nail file and she's all dressed
up in red her favorite color guess goth
was just a phase in this scene she's
playing the role of Alice's mother
Tiffany Valentine as far as the public
record is concerned this woman has never
been married so she doesn't go by
Tiffany Ray when using this identity
from the get-go the two don't get along
and Tiffany casually drops that Alice is
dead which devastates Nica she fakes a
few tears of her own and says that she
suspects Alice's death was due to a
broken heart essentially she wants Nikka
to feel like she's responsible but
messing with Nika was just a bonus the
real purpose of the trip was to smuggle
a new Chucky doll into the mental
hospital that's not the same no no this
is a doll that they used analysis
therapy to help her get over the past
she thought that maybe it would help you
too with her mission accomplished she
leaves two days later on January 25th
she gives Andy Barkley a call and
introduces herself as Tiffany
Jennifer even I lose track which means
she has probably been freely switching
between the two quite a lot I guess
nobody noticed that Tiffany got her
tattoo removed Andy says he knows who
she is and he's coming for her and
Chucky which she responds to by
informing him that there are three of
them at the moment Chucky Tiffany and a
second Chucky she invites Andy to join
the cult which he refuses so she
delivers a message from Chucky it's just
a single word
disembowel Chucky continues to carry out
his plan by inhabiting multiple dolls
inside Harrogate Hospital the only other
thing Tiffany does during this time is
split her own soul into another body
remember how I said she got a second
wedding bell doll it's a good insurance
policy to have a backup in case either
of them gets killed when the time comes
to get out of Harrogate Tiffany
essentially plays the role of getaway
driver which may have brought them
closer together because she was there
for him where his older driver Eddie
Caputo was not I mean he wouldn't have
been on the run in 1988 in the first
place if it wasn't for Tiffany but it's
a nice gesture nonetheless okay not
really and they're both [__] cancer
Chucky walks out after possessing the
body of Nika and Tiffany is just happy
to have her man back in a human body it
didn't matter that it was a woman's body
this time we saw very early on in her
history that she's a bisexual like that
first encounter they make out next to
the dead body in this case the Harrogate
hospital security guard I hope they
didn't do this kind of stuff when Chucky
possessed Alice if you're like me you've
probably wondered at some point during
this story about how law enforcement can
be so totally incompetent Charles Lee
Ray was a well-known serial killer in
the 80s Tiffany had many of her own
run-ins with the law during that time
surely someone saw them together surely
someone noticed that her Disappearance
in 1999 coincided with the appearance of
Charles Leroy's fingerprints on many new
crime scenes surely eyebrows were raised
When Tiffany Valentine reappeared out of
nowhere to adopt the last remaining
family member of Charles Lee Ray's late
mistress well it seems that at some
point between 2017 and 2021
investigators finally connected those
dots and Tiffany Valentine is identified
as a known accomplice to Charles Lee Ray
this information goes public on the
internet she's no longer able to use
that identity so she continues going by
Jennifer Tilly in public and Tiffany Ray
around Chucky my theory is that Andy was
the one to Point Police to the fact that
Charles and Tiffany are affiliated
because when she talks to him on the
phone in cult he tells her I know who
you are in March 2021 Glenn and Glenda
turned 17. so Tiffany can go away on
trips more often and not have to worry
about them as much at some point she
takes Chucky back to Hackensack to
revisit the early parts of their
relationship since there are multiple
Chuckys now I will refer to this version
as Niko Chucky Nika occasionally takes
the driver's seat which Tiffany kind of
likes but pretends not to notice for now
sometimes
when we're together I
see you looking at me
and I know it's you
it's not Chucky
it's you and
I live for those moments if you thought
it was not possible for Chucky and
Tiffany's relationship to get any more
weird and toxic think again despite this
she continues helping Chucky with his
master plan to terrorize America with an
army of Chucky doll to do this she meets
with hackensack's mayor Michelle cross
to propose a benefit screening and
auction the proceeds of the screening
are supposed to fund better days
Children's Hospitals with the dolls
being sent to sick kids across the U.S
each one is a vintage Good Guy doll from
Jennifer's Personal Collection if the
plan works as they hope each of these 72
dolls will be possessed with Charles Lee
Ray's Soul although her feelings for
Chucky are mixed Tiffany could never
pass up an opportunity like this to
spread Mayhem and from mayor cross's
point of view it's a good PR stunt to
promote her re-election a distraction
from the fact that the death toll in her
city has been on the rise the charity
event is scheduled for mid-november on
November 8th 2021 Chucky and Tiffany are
back in the hotel room where they first
made love this time with a new prisoner
and the old arguments start up again
this time about Jennifer's weight which
has basically been on a study incline
the next day she cuts their guests up
into smaller pieces and tries to pack
him into a suitcase and her inability to
do so combined with Chucky's
unwillingness to help causing her to
storm off yet again it's basically the
same fight about the dishes still going
on two decades later in mid-november
Tiff puts her Monsters Inc residuals to
good use and buys Charles Lee Ray's
childhood home in Hackensack to use as a
base of operations for their ever
expanding cult before the deal closes
she sits around with Chucky in their
hotel playing poker a reference to the
real-life Jennifer Tilly's side career
as a professional poker player when she
notices that Nika has covertly taken the
driver's seats it's probably her poker
skills that allow her to easily detect
when control switches from Chucky to
Nika in a 2007 appearance on The Late
Late Show with Craig Ferguson she
discusses how she worked with a
celebrity profiler to learn how to read
her opponent's body language so she
probably picked up on the subtle
differences in Behavior between Chucky
and Tanika Nika is disabled from the
waist down but only when she has the
wheel when Chucky is in control he can
use Nika's legs freely to test her
Theory Tiffany sticks a knife into
Nika's leg and as expected gets no
reaction before revealing that she knows
it's Nika she plays along and tests her
a bit learning that Nika drinks less
beer bites her nails and takes a bigger
risks at least in poker she's able to
trick Nika into revealing her true self
because Tiffany has a great Poker Face
she is not only bluffing in the card
game but also in their conversation
Jennifer Tilly won her first
professional poker tournament in 2005
which works well with her timeline in
the Chucky Universe this is one year
after Tiffany possessed her body so we
can assume it was actually Tiffany who
made her great at poker eventually
Tiffany reveals that she knows it's Nika
and gets choked up as she explains that
she actually prefers being with niga I
live for those moments she claims that
she actually bought the Sherwood Lane
house to share with Nika not Chucky but
honestly I don't even know if she's
telling the truth about that because
she's kind of unraveling at this point
or at least unraveling more than usual
she says that she wants to find a way to
keep Nico in the driver's seat instead
of that rat Chucky but then proceeds
into randomly knock Anika out with a
frying pan I think she's conflicted
about what she wants I know this is a
character analysis video but she's
become so unhinged from the constant
opening and closing the door on her
relationship with Chucky that it almost
doesn't make sense to try to make sense
of her character at this stage if I had
to take a stab at it though no pun
intended it seems like she wants to help
raise Chucky's Army because she likes
spreading Terror but she's leaning
towards Nika from a relationship
standpoint after picking up the keys to
her new house she ties Nick up in the
chair in the living room and leaves her
with a kiss before heading out we don't
know exactly where she goes but my
assumption is that she's meeting with
mayor cross to make sure they're still
on for the benefit screening which would
serve as a positive distraction from the
recent set of murders that have plagued
the town over the last month or so which
of course were caused by Chucky who is
still trying to convince an innocent
soul to kill as part of his ritual
Tiffany's next move is to help Chucky
move this along this time not with her
poker skills but her acting skills
oh
Chucky's new main target is Middle
School student Jake wheeler who
purchased another incarnation of the
doll at a yard sale in October I like to
refer to this one as Coke Chucky the
same Chucky that Alice supposedly used
to cope with the massacre of her family
in an attempt to make Jake more
emotionally distraught Coke Chucky kills
Jake's father then kills the ant that
took him in Brie wheeler however Jake
still refuses to kill but Chucky
realizes that there may be another child
who will Jake's cousin Junior Tiffany
plays a part in driving Junior to the
brink of homicide one day not long after
buying the house Tiffany shows up at
Bree's wake she makes a big entrance
walks up smiling to The Grieving widower
and plants a kiss on his lips although
her motive isn't clear at the moment
this is part of a larger effort to piss
off Junior and turn him against his dad
by making him think that his mother
killed herself because Logan was having
an affair she continues to push this
idea when she brings over a meal for the
morning family and a junior comes to the
door to receive it she tells him that
it's important to have a woman in the
house and plans for the idea of herself
as the mother figure in Junior's life
which fires him up because he only just
lost his mom Tiffany pretends like she's
slipped up and said too much before
leaving this income combination with
Chucky hammering at home later cancer
wasn't enough huh you had to cheat on
her too real Classics dad finally pushes
Junior to kill his dad and completes
Chucky's Voodoo ritual this all ties
into the part that Jennifer Tilly is
supposed to play at the benefit screen
that evening Tiffany comes home and
discovers Nika Chucky has gotten out of
the chair and finds her laying on the
ground she assumes that Nika's in
control unable to get up due to her
paralyzed legs but this assumption ends
up being incorrect when she receives a
powerful kick knocking her to the ground
this is Chucky and he straddles her with
a knife and threatens to kill her for
the fourth time Tiffany begs that he
can't kill her because he still needs
her and she's absolutely correct
I'm thinking is for losers
hey again she's right bro we need her
it's interesting how she's developed
this animosity towards the Charles Lee
Ray living unica's body but when she
sees one inside of a doll body she
lights up and refers to him as sweet
face they're the same person it's just
that she's been spending a lot more time
with the one in Nika's body so their
toxic relationship has turned them
against each other [__] you Chucky
thank you
people I brought up earlier in this
lesson Chucky is a romantic partner to
her but she treats him like a baby
it's just weird man she takes cope
Chucky downstairs to where the Army has
awakened she also finds Jake's friend
Devin who's tied up and a junior who has
joined the side of the bad guys after
Chucky gives a speech to his troops
Tiffany sees to it that the army of
Chucky's is packed into the transport
truck and stows Away the doll version of
herself to facilitate things in case the
plan gets off track she plans to meet
the driver the following day at the
theater back in the basement it's
basically a party for the bad guy she
tries to talk to cope Chucky who brushes
her off as he's busy catching up with
nikachaki she gets especially butt hurt
when mikichuki brags about being able to
pick up women even in a woman's body
Tiffany mentions that girl on girl isn't
the only thing that Nika Chucky is
getting she's talking about this causes
Tiffany to blow up on nikachuki and slap
him which seems to knock Chucky out of
the driver's seat and give control back
to Nika at least she treats me with a
little respect cope Chucky senses what's
going on between Nika and Tiffany and
offers an apology for his self-righteous
attitude but it comes with a caveat
killer you know what that does to me
this leaves Tiffany mustard she argues
that Nika holds a part of Chucky's Soul
as well but he doesn't care since there
are 72 other Chuckies on the truck she
reluctantly agrees in tears who is it
you're afraid of losing Tiff
me or her when Tiffany doesn't act he
orders Junior to do it but before he can
muster the courage Tiff retaliates by
attacking the doll and cutting his head
off which he picks up and delivers
another dramatic breakup speech too
Chucky threatens to kill her with one of
his many incarnations but she boasts
that he needs her too much she brings
out a suitcase which she explains to be
a present from Glenda the violent one of
her two twins the luggage is filled with
bombs which she sets as a trap for Andy
Barkley when he inevitably arrives
Tiffany Jr and one of the 72 dolls that
Junior stall are loaded up into the car
and don't emerge again until the next
day when the mayor introduces Jennifer
Tilly at the benefit screening and
auction during the announcement the
mayor's youngest daughter Caroline
throws a fit because she wants a Chucky
doll so Tiffany gives her one extra I'm
sure one measly little sick child can
take care of himself here's sweetheart
your very own good guy girl she doesn't
seem to stay for the screening which is
odd because it's a prequel to the movie
that she was so moved by and Bride of
Frankenstein I'm guessing she's got
other things to do like meeting up with
the driver and briefing him on when the
plane leaves and how she's gonna kill
him if he's late with that she gets into
her car and turns around to see that
Andy has hijacked the truck
foreign
not All Is Lost though she must have
forgotten about her backup plan or maybe
the Tantrum was just part of her
performance to get Andy to let his guard
down before this happens
the doll version of Tiffany breaks the
window and introduces herself to Andy by
holding him at gunpoint and ordering him
to drive to the airport if he knows
what's good for meanwhile the human
version of Tiffany goes back to her
favorite room at the hotel Hackensack
with Nika who is incapacitated it's not
clear how she snuck Nika's unconscious
body upstairs without drawing suspicion
but given that she's a disposal expert
it's not hard to imagine that she'd also
be good at smuggling live bodies she
also had less weight to carry because as
a preventative measure she decided to
cut off all of Nika's lens this way
Chucky can't go anywhere no matter what
can't kick her and can't kill her as he
promised back at the base
[Music]
yeah as Tiffany holds Andy at gunpoint
three good guy dolls from Chucky's Army
escape from their boxes and have their
own conversation in the back it seems
that they don't recognize Andy and
Tiffany right away which Andy points out
they don't know me
either I don't know what she did this
distracts Tiffany so Andy is able to
Swerve making her drop her gun he picks
it up and blows her head off and that is
the end of the doll Tiffany that was
introduced in cult that just leaves
Tiffany living in Jennifer Tilly's body
she isolates herself and Nika in the
Beverly Hills house and decorates Nika's
room to look like a doll's room
Tiffany's obsession with dolls is
projected on Anika and she treats her
like a doll dressing her up feeding her
and mothering her despite Nika's
discomfort with this in addition to all
of Tiffany's other problems she becomes
essentially agoraphobic according to the
Mayo Clinic agoraphobia involves fearing
and avoiding places or situations that
might cause panic and feelings of being
trapped helpless or embarrassed it's
often described as the fear of going
outside which may be a result of the
authorities closing in on niga's
location she uses a security system app
allowing her to monitor All Points of
entry into the property so she can
always know who's coming and who's going
Tiffany spends most of her time making
Nico watch Jennifer Tilly movies with
her like when they watch liar liar she
repeats all of Jennifer's lines as if it
was her who played that part she's
reveling in the past just like the
character Norma Desmond Sunset Boulevard
only she's obsessed with Jennifer's past
not her own Nikki criticizes her for
living this way and points out that this
lifestyle is not sustainable in the long
run claiming I know you went through all
of Jennifer Tilly Simpson's money
how does someone go through 100 million
dollars Tiffany brushes this off saying
it's not easy being me it's not cheap
being me either however her sense of
safety is shattered in November of 2022
When Tiffany wakes up to find the doll
version of her head under the covers
with her after feeding Nika breakfast
she pulls out her nail file and cuts her
own hand open and the sight of blood
forces Nika to relinquish control to
Chucky Tiffany freaks out and assumes
Chucky is responsible to which Chucky
responds that he's coming for her we
still don't really know how the doll had
got there considering nikachuki has no
way of communicating with the others and
the multiple Chuckies are not a hive
mind situation perhaps if a new Chucky
is created he would begin with all the
information of the past Chuckies and
thus no nikachuki's location however we
don't know of any new Chuckies being
created between the movie theater
incidents and the doll head wake-up call
Tiffany prepares for Glenn and Glenda's
birthday weekend the Twins were born in
March not November but they were busy
they were in school look the birthday is
just in November now okay to keep Nika
quiet during the festivities Tiffany
asks if she'd prefer the ball gag or
chloroform but their conversation is
interrupted once again her security
system is breached as a detective rings
the doorbell Tiffany meets detective
Gavin who is investigating the missing
person's case of Nick appear caught off
guard Tiffany tells him that she knows
nothing and shuts the door on him hoping
that he'll go away which he does but
only temporarily the next day Tiffany is
preparing the birthday cakes when she
hears the gay chime assumes that it's
the Twins and allows access to the house
but when she gets to the door it's
detective Gavin again insisting that he
thinks Jennifer Tilly is likely hiding
Nick appears in a panic Tiffany splits
his throat and with no time to properly
dispose of him she jams his body into a
coat closet and tries to mop up the
blood with one of her sweaters just as
Glenn and Glenda walk in after so many
years and so much plotting she finds
herself back in the familiar position of
trying to hide her violent true nature
from her kids they both seem shocked and
surprised to see blood suggesting that
maybe Glenda was too young to remember
witnessing Tiffany kill the nanny on her
fifth birthday Tiffany plays off the
blood as just corn syrup explaining that
the violent content is what her fans
want this is enough to pacify Glenn and
Glenda as a reminder they think that
their mom is the actress Jennifer Tilly
and they don't really know who Tiffany
Valentine is as they talk the twins
reveal that they know that their mom is
having money trouble which makes her
defensive as she tries to change the
subject Glenn asks who Nika Pierce is
again catching her by surprise as the
twins are not supposed to know anything
about Nika Tiffany wavers back and forth
between claiming that Nika is someone
that she barely knows to saying that
she's an obsessed stalker which is why
she needs all the security in the midst
of this Glenn gets up to look for a cell
phone charger and Glenda uses the
opportunity to ask if there's anything
that she's hidden from them because both
of them keep having the same nightmare
Glenda describes this nightmare which
involved letting the woman on fire and a
man addressing someone named Tiffany
realizing that Glenda somehow remembers
killing Jennifer's assistant in 2004
panics and blames it on Glenn and
Glenda's very active imaginations to
prevent them from finding the room that
Nika's in she hires a butler and even
gives him a fancy name geez he's very
original we have no idea where Tiffany
found this guy or what his deal is but
she puts him in charge of guarding the
door to Nico's room while she's leading
him to his post she startled defining
The Glenn trying to get into that same
room Tiffany quickly shuts this down and
tries to play it off as if it's no big
deal claiming that all of her shoes are
in there as Tiffany walks back to the
living room she's met with another
surprise literally
apparently Glenn and Glenda arranged
their own surprise party with Gina
Gershon Sutton Strack and Joe pantoliano
the whole situation turns into a huge
intervention of her friends wanting to
know why Jennifer disappeared on them
for the past year but things get worse
for Tiffany when Jennifer's sister Meg
Tilly arrives while everyone else has
been ghosted for only one year Meg had
been ghosted for 20. Tiffany does her
best to brush the whole thing off but
Meg isn't having it and pleads for
answers as Tiffany does a wardrobe
change to look more appropriate for the
party she puts on the dress Jennifer
Tilly wore to the Academy Award as
little does Tiffany know the whole party
was all a distraction so that Glenn and
Glenda could help Nika Escape Glenda
slips him arsenic into Jeeves drink
killing him and leaving the doors to
Nika's room unguarded When Tiffany and
the dinner guest discovered Jeeves body
and the now empty bedroom Tiff acts fast
and convinces everyone that this is a
murder mystery dinner party and that
Jeeves is just acting this works to her
Advantage because she too needs to find
out who killed Jeeves so that she can
use that person to find the missing Nika
as everyone investigates Tiffany has two
separate bedroom encounters one with
Gina Gershon and the other with Joe
pantoliano both of which serves you
further distracts her from Nika's Escape
until Chucky regains control of Nika's
body and sneaks up on her as she's
interrogating Meg pulling a gun into her
face I'm almost Gonna Miss You Tiff
almost
[Music]
I think it's fair to say by this point
Chucky and Tiffany went from being a
toxic couple to being toxic exes the
initial attraction that kept drawing
them back to each other does seem to
genuinely be gone and now they're just
trying to kill each other however to
Chucky's surprise the gun is empty
giving Tiffany the chance to slap Nika
in the face which just like when Glenn
slash Glenda was a doll forces Nika to
switch back to her true self as Nika
awakens she realizes this is her last
chance for escape and truly books it out
of there using the prosthetic arms Glenn
and Glenda argue about leaving with Nika
Glenn is appalled that Glenda almost
allowed their mom to be killed and opts
to stay with Tiffany while Glenda takes
off with Nika to try to get to the
bottom of what's really going on Tiffany
throws an absolute tantrum at the
thought of losing her beloved Nika and
tries to close the gate before she can
get away but Nika and Glenda make it
through just in time and are taken away
by a very ADA Compliant van that's
waiting on the streets Tiffany is Left
Behind in a mess and on top of
everything that just transpired Glenn
asks who Tiffany Valentine is but their
conversation gets interrupted Gina and
Sutton go home thinking that they just
attended a really believed murder
mystery party but Meg isn't ready to
give up and stays overnight confronting
Tiffany the next morning and demanding a
connection with her sister when Tiffany
asked Meg when she plans on leaving she
says she won't leave until she gets some
answers seeing that she's backed into a
trap Tiffany gets desperate she leaves
the room and goes into what looks like a
storage room in her house she's got a
lot of secret rooms in this house she
pulls the cover off of a cage over the
real Jennifer Tilly who is living in
Tiffany's old adult form is being held
captive it probably would have made
sense for her to just hide Nika in here
during the party you know keep your
prisoners all in one place Tiffany
ignores her pleas for chocolate and
tells her that her sister is upstairs
and she needs to know who the Dean
brothers are Jennifer realizes this
could be her last chance to see her
sister or possibly Escape so instead of
telling about the Dean Brothers she
explains the plot of the movie The Blues
Brothers When Tiffany recounts this to
Meg she realizes this and becomes even
more suspicious feeling embarrassed she
storms back into the storage room but
this time she's followed by Megan Glenn
who discover who this little prisoner is
Tiffany pulls out her classic nail file
and gives everyone manicures now now
that's not what happens she brutally
kills Maggie in front of her long-lost
sister that's one way to put a damper on
the family reunion Glenn who has always
been sheltered from Tiffany's evil side
watches in horror who are you
my name is Tiffany Valentine and I'm
your goddamn mother as Tiffany sits down
and explains everything to Glenn she
says that she has one last birthday
present the original Glenn slash Glenda
doll they both vow that they need to go
find Glenda Tiffany was once heralded as
the body disposal expert but I guess she
figured that hiding the body sitting in
her house wouldn't do much good because
police would probably know that
detective Gavin's last whereabouts were
at her Mansion Jennifer Tilly was about
to become a fugitive no matter what that
being said I still don't get why she
sets the house on fire it seems
extremely unnecessary but then again
she's not exactly a stable person she
drives off in her red Pontiac with
Jennifer and Glenn it doesn't take long
for word to hit the news that the famous
actress is a murderer but that doesn't
stop her from being swarmed by fans at a
Roadside Diner I can't tell if this is a
dumb scene or some kind of scathing
commentary on how people idolize
celebrities too much I don't know why
she didn't just switch back into the
doll body at this point the only thing I
can figure is that she kind of knows
that once she returns to being a doll
gen Jennifer Tilly is going to be
arrested so she's savoring her final
moments in a human body that resembles
her own she does plan to trade places
with Jennifer again but Jennifer no
longer wants her own body now that she's
wanted for murder so she escapes the car
and makes a run for it but her Escape is
cut short when she's destroyed by a semi
truck leaving Tiffany without a plan B
but first things first Tiffany and
Glenn's priority is getting back to
Glenda so they continue the
cross-country road trip back to where it
all began New Jersey Tiffany and Glenn
show up at the Catholic School of the
Incarnate Lord later that week and
discover all that has happened Chucky
was separated from Nika's body and
Glenda informs Glenn that their father
is dead however as we all know Chucky
always comes back but we'll get to that
later Tiffany somehow more of an
emotional wreck than usual tries to talk
to Nika but Nika pulls a gun on her
hungry for revenge for everything that
Tiff has put her through Glenn being the
more sheltered non-violent twin Dives in
front of Tiffany to save her and takes
the bullet Tiffany and Glenda rush her
to the hospital but due to Jennifer
Tilly being wanted for murder only
Glenda can go inside Glenn goes into a
coma and is not expected to live much
longer so on December 22nd 2022 Tiffany
devises a plan to sneak in and transfer
the twins back into the doll I don't
really understand why Glenda can't just
do it I mean Tiffany is just going off
the voodoo For Dummies book anyway but
I'm not an expert on Voodoo and there's
probably a very good reason that this
particular Soul transfer has to be
performed by a third party the plan is
nearly foiled when a police officer
discovers them but a quick thinking
Tiffany smashes him over the head with
the vase shortly after Glenda's
murderous side comes out
this allows Tiffany to execute the
voodoo ritual and leave with Glenn slash
Glenda packed safely in a suitcase while
the twins abandoned human bodies lay in
the hospital bed for this unfortunate
nurse to find
foreign
fact these are not dead bodies they're
just abandoned vessels which means I can
show them I've been waiting for my whole
career for something like this to happen
Tiffany gives Glenn slash Glenda a
makeover and asks what she should call
the unified child now everyone agrees
that the name GG would be appropriate he
got one G for Glenn you got the other G
for Glenda it's perfect also Gigi's
English accent comes back for some
reason in addition to the sudden desire
to go to England Tiffany supports this
and offers a ride to the post office
using the same method of travel that
she's used for Chucky many times in the
past that just leaves the question of
where she'll be depositing her own soul
and the answer comes when she sees
hackensack's former mayor live streaming
her Christmas decorating we will just
assume this is a burner phone because
police haven't figured out her location
yet Mrs cross has a wedding bell doll
which is exactly the type of doll that
Tiffany needs to return to doll form
realizing this is her one chance she
goes to Michelle cross's house on
Christmas Eve but to her surprise the
doll is missing from the nativity scene
in the front yard when she arrives she
sneaks into the house and is immediately
discovered by Mrs cross who instead of
being alone armed by wanted killer
Jennifer Tilly being in her home is
Starstruck and tries to use her for
social media Cloud this is cut short
though when Chucky I told you she'd be
back lunges out with a chainsaw and
slices Michelle in half he's about to go
for Tiffany when Michelle's oldest
daughter Lexi drops down from the stairs
and pins him to the ground while she
revs up his chainsaw Chucky pleads with
Tiffany to help him but she demonstrates
that she's truly done with him and walks
away to go find the Bell doll she finds
it in the younger sister Caroline's room
but quickly finds herself cornered by
Jake Devin and Lexi however just as the
teenagers seem to have her completely
trapped Caroline walks out and hands
Tiffany a knife before basically giving
herself up as a hostage and explaining
that she's been loyal to Chucky the
whole time she's been brainwashed into
believing that her real family is not
actually her real family and that
Tiffany is actually her mom Caroline has
been waiting for the day that Tiffany
would come for her Tiffany who loves an
excuse to Mother anything leaves with
Caroline and flees to New York City
where she changes her looks to this Uma
Thurman kind of haircut and survives
Incognito for a few weeks he he seems to
think she's in the clear until late
January 2023 when she gets a call from
niga Nika first apologizes for nearly
killing Glenn but that makes it clear
that she's still close with the GG
Tiffany reacts to this in a way that
makes it seem likely that Nika probably
talks to Gigi more than she does but
before she can get too upset Nika lets
her know that she knows where she is and
she's going to kill her but allows her
to get a head start so Tiffany tries to
do the dembele ritual but like always it
doesn't initially work
sass possess possess possess possess you
stupid dog the doll does sit up but
things don't go how Tiffany had planned
this is no Bell doll at all but rather
Chucky in Disguise it becomes clear to
Tiffany that Chucky and Caroline have
set her up Chucky lunges at her with his
knife while Tiffany screams helplessly
on the floor that's the last we see of
Tiffany Valentine for now at the end of
the season it seems like Tiffany may
have finally met her demise at the hands
of Chucky this is something that he's
been attempting to do for a few years
now and it looks like he may have
finally succeeded however there's also
the possibility that Tiffany's dumbbell
ritual may have delayed effects as it
has in the past and she could be
transferred into Chucky at the last
minute this could force the two to share
her body and create some really
interesting Dynamics in the future we'll
have to keep watching to find out so if
you want my updated analysis of Tiffany
as New Seasons or movies are released
and you want to see my character
analysis timelines of other Chucky
franchise characters make sure you
subscribe to cz's world for new Horrors
every week ring the death bell and
select notifications and I will see you
in the next one assuming we both survive
[Music]